[Music]
breakfast lunch and dinner
whether it's at my restaurants or at
home i think food should always stand up
and be noticed it doesn't matter if a
dish is light and delicate or full-on
and gutsy the flavors should be distinct
and clear and that means always getting
the maximum taste from your ingredients
today it's all about vibrant muscular
food so fasting your seatbelt for my
ultimate breakfast lunch and dinner
packed with big and bold flavors
first up a punchy breakfast of murgues
and fontina stuffed croissants
flavor there is incredible
for lunch a spicy mexican soup be
adventurous but beware
serve with quick tortilla chips and a
peek of the guy or dip
maggie
for dinner i'll be setting the world to
write with my eldest megan
you're so annoying i'm so annoyed when
we make one of her favorite dishes
crispy roast duck with pancakes and
black bean dipping sauce
seen as is your favorite that you can
make it
followed by a spiced banana tart to tan
wow
these are my ultimate recipes for a day
bursting with their big and bold
breakfast lunch and dinner
starting with a breakfast that can't
fail to wake you up
merguez and fontina stuffed croissants
okay big and bold i was living in france
i stayed there for three years once
twice a week i treated myself to the
most amazing
bold breakfast and it started off with
these beauties here murgays cheap but
incredibly tasty
start off with a nice hot pan
murgay's in
it's a very spicy sausage doesn't need
any help doesn't even need chili
just a touch
of salt and pepper
you can smell
the spice
they're starting to release all that
wonderful oil that flavor in there
add a couple of cloves i'll finely slice
garlic
spread the garlic across the pan it
instantly changes color takes on this
nice dark rich
golden color
now take a look with the heat out with
the parsley
the stalks of soft herbs like parsley
and coriander can be used to impart
flavor during cooking but the leaves
should always be added just before
serving to give maximum colour and
fragrance
[Music]
and then finish that off with my capers
amazing
all right
beautiful
now
take your quests on
they're literally 24 hours old so
they're crispy on the outside and just
slice off
the lid
this recipe is a great way to use up any
leftover croissants from the day before
i used to cringe when i saw the french
cooks throw away croissants i used to
cry thinking oh my god
any idea what you're throwing away in
terms of flavor
whatever you do do not wipe out that pan
dunk
your croissants mopping up all that
amazing flavor and caramelizing the
inside
for that beautiful and don't forget the
lids
and then get your thumbs and go inside
the croissant
all i want to do now is just create a
little pocket
and just manipulate the crescent now
this is where it gets exciting
mix up
the capers the garlic and sausages
look at the color
of that wonderful
delicious flavoured
oil now some cheese
but not just any cheese fontina cheese
is like the number one cheese for
grilling and because it's a very rich
cheese you shave it thinner than you
would a white truffle but it gives a
really nice saltiness and a light smokey
flavour
a touch of pepper
salt
place these big boys on the tray
literally 30 seconds
on the grill
here we go
nice
crisp
packed full of flavor
now top them
and that for me
it's almost like being back in paris
except this time
i don't have to share them with the
french
my ultimate big and bold breakfast
murgays and fontina stuffed croissants a
great way to start the day
[Music]
never be scared of trying new flavors in
your cooking
a few key ingredients can make all the
difference here's a closer look at some
i'll be using later
peppercorns may be small but whatever
the color in terms of flavor they're one
of the heavy weights of the kitchen
with the exception of the pink type all
peppercorns are fruits from the same
flowering vine
it's the stage at which they are
harvested and how they are processed
that determines their unique colors and
tastes
[Music]
today i'll be using the fiery black and
perfume pink types to add a big bold
punch to my pudding
[Music]
for dinner i'll be cooking duck hugely
popular in chinese cuisine this bird may
be less meaty than a chicken but its
intense rich flavor means the meat goes
a long long way
[Music]
wild or farmed duck meat is packed with
protein vitamins and essential nutrients
and i'm going to slow roast one in my
dinner dish of crispy roast duck with
pancakes
chilis are a fabulous ingredient and one
of my absolute favorites is the chipotle
chipotles begin life as a green jalapeno
pepper the process of drying and smoking
lends an intense smoky flavor to balance
their spicy heat
dried chipotles can be brought as a
paste powder or whole which is how i'll
be using them in my big bold lunch
chilies come in all shapes and sizes and
heat and are used throughout the world
but if there's one cuisine that has
really turned cooking them into an art
form it's mexican they're experts at
building layer upon layer flavored with
delicious chilies and spices so for my
ultimate big and bold lunch spicy
mexican soup
it's hearty delicious robust but served
with some tortillas and a wonderful
salsa it's almost like a complete meal
in one
starting with some finely chopped red
onions for my soup
let's get some heat going early these
are chipotle so they're smoky rich they
don't come with any warning signal and
these are seriously hot so
be adventurous
but beware
a nice teaspoon
of toasted cumin
oregano dried now start frying off
spices the heat
you'll see the chilies start swelling up
delicious
garlic
be quite generous on the oil because
that helps to blow out the chili
right now those onions and garlic
are on fire
we're going to balance the sort of heat
from the chipotle with sugar
turn up the heat
and really start caramelizing that sugar
and the chili
gives off the most amazing
aroma
next fry up a tablespoon of tomato puree
add a can of chopped tomatoes
cook kidney beans
and vegetable or chicken stock to cover
there's something quite exciting about
big and bold flavors because in the
restaurants you have to be somewhat
controlled you can't go crazy
so cooking these kind of dishes at home
gives me that kind of release
chilis particularly when they're dried
continue to swell and release their heat
as they're cooked so the longer you cook
your dish the hotter it will be
[Music]
but it's not as powerful it needs to be
yet
and every five six seven eight minutes
that's gonna get stronger
hotter and more delicious
bring that up to the ball and cook that
out for 15 minutes
whilst i allow the chili heat to infuse
i'm going to crack on with quick crunchy
tortilla chips and a fabulously fresh
and spicy tomato salsa known in mexico
as pico de gallo
start by finely dicing three ripe
tomatoes
one or two deseeded fresh jalapeno
peppers
and half a red onion
then chop a good handful of fresh
coriander
add the juice from two limes
salt and pepper
and a drizzle of extra virgin olive oil
for the tortilla chips rub a little
olive oil onto six large shop bought
wheat wraps
sprinkle with smoked paprika and gently
massage in
cut each wrap into triangles and spread
them onto a baking tray
bake for three to four minutes in a
preheated oven 180 degrees until golden
brown and leave to cool
to complete my mexican lunch i need to
finish my deliciously fragrant spicy
soup
the spice is there
it is
absolutely spot on
now for the cooling down process
the mexicans are brilliant at building
layer upon layer of flavor with
delicious chilies and spices but they're
also experts at tempering their dishes
with cooling ingredients like avocado
sour cream and cheese that's why you can
take that amount of chili you don't have
a spoon of richness spice and all of a
sudden avocados almost like a little
fire blanket over those chillies
to further counter the chilli heat
mexicans use a rich tangy crumbly cheese
but i'm sprinkling on lancashire which
is a great british substitute
and last but not least
cooling fresh coriander
one delicious spicy mexican soup
serve that with your tortilla chips and
your pico de gallo salsa
a phenomenal blend of textures and
layers and spice and creaminess big bold
and delicious
one of the secrets to making fantastic
food at home is learning to be confident
when you're using strong flavors all
dishes need to be balanced but don't be
afraid of using herbs and spices to make
your cooking vibrant and exciting
here's my ultimate big and bold dinner a
meal that demands to be taken notice of
[Music]
and helping me in the kitchen is my
eldest daughter megan
crispy roasted up with pancakes
with the addy kick of a black bean
dipping sauce
megan
gonna help with the duck danny your
favorite yes it is now how's your
boyfriend
right i'm going
come on
that woke you up didn't it
so what do you love most about duck the
dipping sauce the dipping sauce i love
that uh let's get the duck in the oven
first
let's get a bit of salt in there please
then some pepper thank you
some spring onion garlic and ginger now
why do you think we pour that in there
to season it and flavor it
how come you put them in hole like that
and not smaller it's going inside i'm
not using it for sauce or anything so
it's just going to make it really nice
what are they
star anise sorry
so what happens as the duck roasts on
the outside it creates this really nice
perfume aroma inside
tuck that in there to get it spicy rub
all that chinese five spice yeah over
almost like you're massaging
good
so make sure you get it all in even the
little wings you know underneath her
just like i used to do to you my bath
i used to wash your little handys
i know those days are long gone i know i
know i know dad
that is seriously spicy with the duck
there's generally quite a lot of fat
there yeah so we're gonna put it on this
little bench
okay
and that
goes
there
by slowly roasting it okay it's gonna
get nice and crisp on the outside all
that fat is gonna render inside the
breast so therefore it's gonna get all
nice and juicy yeah
right ducks in
three and a half hours at 160 degrees
celsius
your favorite part you said was the
dipping sauce why is it your favorite
part i think it really adds to the dark
it makes it really tasty cena's is your
favorite you can make it i'm gonna do
nothing okay daddy's gonna put his feet
up so
uh first off the garlic there's one good
girl watch your fingers please always do
good
nice
oh you're fast
huh watch your fingers i am
watch your fingers slide slow down
please
14.
all right that's enough
right little teaspoon of olive oil
in a few years time i'll be teaching
how to drive
as well as cook how exciting is that you
know in a car
scary
okay garlickin
crispy duck is traditionally served with
hoisin sauce but my brood love the
additional big bold punch of black beans
nice
megan and i add soy sauce and lastly for
that classic chinese sweet and sour
element brown rice vinegar and honey
[Music]
are you happy with the flavour i'm
really happy
can you taste everything in there
dipping sauce done ducks in the oven
let's start the dessert
the most amazing tata tan are those pink
peppercorns they are pink peppercorns
they're really good they don't taste
anything like black peppercorns quite
sweet aren't they they're really sweet
very fruity the pink peppercorns give it
the sweetness the black peppercorns give
the heat
now
what is that baby
vanilla
this is one of the easiest desserts in
the world to make but one of the most
delicious it's a sort of take on the
classic apple or pear to tan but when
you caramelize those bananas with the
peppercorns
and the vanilla i bet that tastes
amazing oh my goodness incredible
okay i'm gonna make the camera start off
with the cold pen first
and you just press that button in there
how come do you do it like that and not
let it just melt naturally because i
want the butter to stay cold because i'm
gonna stick the bananas in there okay
and then we'll make the caramel and
caramelize the bananas at the same time
so in goes those
vanilla vanilla seeds pods in there as
well
okay peppercorns done yeah well done
good girl sprinkle them over that butter
just naturally naturally yeah
nice and then look just very carefully
sprinkle sugar
over that
you're doing them all the same size
roughly the same size
wedge it into the butter
well do you know what want the bananas
really caramelized
you just stuck them between
if you crown them in like this okay it
will stop them moving around
nothing's moving nothing is okay it's
all wedged in there
spreading the peppercorns on top of the
bananas so you can feel that flavor
in the caramel and on the top and the
bottom
right
puff pastry
puff pastry is difficult and time
consuming to make so i always buy
ready-made when i'm at home
to get the best flavor and texture go
for the all butter type and keep your
pastry cold before using it
this is where it gets really exciting
you get your fingers you just pinch the
end so you thin the end if you do that
for me very carefully you have to be
quick because the heat your fingers can
melt the pastry how comes you do it dad
because we get it nice and thin so we
can clip it underneath
now take a spoon
and what we do is lift up that banana
and tuck it underneath
see little parcel like a parcel and see
the thin bits of pastry yeah how easy it
is to get it underneath yeah and that's
why you thin them out
you do it so quickly well because i have
to be quick otherwise the pastry will
melt
notice how we're not using anything
sharp so we're not would that cut the
pastry that's right
see how locked down that is
[Music]
gas on
we'll start caramelizing her
those three little holes are so
important
if we didn't put a hole in the pastry
and it will cause a lot of steam so the
pastry never cooks it just goes really
soggy okay so really important the
caramel is live now we're working the
camel give a little shake how can you
see the caramel through the pastry look
what happens when it tilts
oh yeah see all comes running down
see yeah i see
now that pastry okay it's like clinging
on to the bananas and so when we turn it
upside down we've got this glove full of
these caramelized bananas
look at that wow
it looks like look a locky
looking lucky ah look at likey got it
now baby
you're very annoying i'm sorry
it's your birthday soon 15.
i've just worked it out
i'm my 50th
you're 18. perfect we should do a joint
party yeah love it twelve two four for
the old ones twelve lunches have time
till four for the old one so they can go
to sleep megan we'll go on later come on
perfect
here's where i get excited now look at
the color of that caramel so tilt the
pan again see how dark it is now yeah
wow it's going a lot darker now it
didn't take long didn't take long at all
that's nearly ready for the oven but
before i put that in i'll get the duck
out
wow
how's the duck doing
crispy
wow
and delicious
how crispy that is it's really crispy
that's what happens when it slow cooks
so 20 minutes for the duck to rest and
20 minutes in the oven 190 to 200
degrees for our banana tartar tan
time to knock up a quick hoisin and
cucumber salad to put in our crispy duck
pancakes
for the dressing combine hoisin sauce
rice wine vinegar
soy sauce
a dash of sesame oil
and to give it that zingy asian punch
some freshly grated root ginger
[Music]
for the salad trim and cut spring onions
into very fine matchsticks
peel a whole cucumber into long thin
ribbons
and shred in a couple of baby gem
lettuces
season and toss this fresh crunchy salad
in the sweet yummy hoisin dressing
a combination that never fails to get
the kids eating their greens
wow look at that
so
see now where that pastry is
caramelizing caramel so dark and just
a little tip gas back on
and that will release it
because if you tip it and it's still
sticking
then some of your bananas
will stick yeah so now see when it
starts spinning around like this
moving around and here we are the moment
of truth
when you know your daddy
is the best chef in the world
ready
yep
wow
the vanilla
how delicious
is really good as well
right start to stand out done crispy
dipping sauce
cucumber salad ready so if you take them
and your dipping sauce take them over
thank you i'll take the duck
don't drop it promise
oh
okay
it was amazing
my ultimate big and bold dinner of
crispy roast duck with pancakes
with a hoisin dressed salad and some
extra oomph from megan's favorite black
bean dipping sauce
nice
ollie i think you need a bit more duck
in there you heard me home
honestly it's like a black burrito
and for a big and bold pudding delicious
spiced banana tartar tan
jack's gonna be so hot can i have a
little bit of me
i think we might have to save him some
swimming makes him very hungry that's
saving the wishbone of the duck that's
me
[Music]
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
you